all right so we're here at the property
just pulled up we picked some apples out
on the road when we first come in to
give the deer a little bit more
of a treat in the back uh today
we're going to be working on adding a
manual timer to the solar
panel or the solar power box for the
fountain
and then hopefully get the fountain to
turn on and figure out how to do this
timer
it's kind of confusing let's get to it
i'm going to hop in the truck and get a
few things
and we'll head over to the solar power
box
and i will show you guys what's going on
all right i just want to explain what's
going on here this is our
solar box that is our panel that we
still have not built a frame for
uh since this is just experimental this
box is just a cheap box from
the parts store or the hardware store
in here we have a deep cycle 12 volt
battery
connected to a solar
charger a regulator
that runs to the solar panel and then
runs to the battery
so that is constantly connected it's
probably hard to see
but we finally have high voltage then we
have
a 500 watt power inverter
and this box was built to take this
extension cord right here
and run the pond we hooked it up
and everything worked however the
battery died so i just want to go
over how we had it hooked up before and
why it died
and then what we're going to do to fix
that
this here is a manual timer basically
you plug it into your wall
you set the time then you take these
little pins
and you push them down to the time that
you want the power to be on
and this thing just goes and keeps track
of time and then whenever the time gets
to these little pins
the power will kick on and
so i had this hooked up to the inverter
and then i had that pump
hooked up to this now the only thing
that sucked about this setup
was constantly 100 percent
of the time the inverter had to be on
now this inverter pulled more power
than the charger could keep up with
overnight which would kill the battery
so it would be charging
during the day and running so
the just keeping this on 100 of the time
was not an option so the next thing i
looked up
was maybe coming up with an arduino
or a twino board or something that
went in between the battery and the
power inverter and would kick off and on
and it would use let's say a six bolt
reference
well that was okay but then i ran into
this what we're going to do is hook this
up
to the battery the 12 volt lead here
and then we're going this is the switch
side so the switch side is basically
going to
we're going to splice the power run it
in and run it back
out so it says it can take up to a 250
volt 16 amp
so i'm a little skeptic because these
connectors here are just the quarter
inch connectors
and uh we're going to be running the
power inverter and
ultimately our homemade pond fountain
which was made out of a
fifth horsepower sump pump
so that's that let's uh go ahead and get
started on this
[Music]
all right i want to give you guys a
rundown on the solar power box for the
fountain the
first version of this box was pretty
straightforward we had
a 12 volt deep cycle battery an inverter
and 100 watt solar panel
solar panel obviously ran to the solar
uh charge controller
then tapped into the battery and the
idea was to
use the inverter with a manual timer
that we could then plug our diy
sump pump into for the fountain
however what we ran into with this
manual timer
is the inverter needed to stay on
uh 100 of the time even when
i didn't need the power but the inverter
needed to stay on to operate
this uh what ended up happening was
literally the first day
the battery was drained just from
the power that the inverter used just to
even be on not even pulling
power for the pump so
what i opted to do this time was to go
to a digital
timer and this timer
allows for 20 settings and it's a 12
volt dc
um timer that runs off
of a 12 volt reference which happened to
be these two wires
and basically uh
these two wires on the right hand side
are
the power the positive lead to
the inverter
the way this works is you set the timer
on this to to turn on and whatever time
you tell it to turn on and turn off
then what it'll do it will
basically supply power to the power side
of the inverter
and the inverter will turn on so the
entire system will turn on
based off of this system this system has
a self battery or it can sustain itself
for i believe three weeks
without a 12 volt reference but the
battery charges off of this
and doesn't use much power at all
what that did was alleviated the
constant draw on the inverter and
literally the inverter all i do is i
leave the power on
on the inverter and the timer will just
kick off and on when i want it to
so at 3 30 this thing is supposed to
shut off
and we're gonna see if the pond fountain
shuts off
get out my other phone here
the diy solar power box
with the timer
five seconds
[Laughter]
oh look at that we have success
that did exactly what it was supposed to
do how awesome
is that we have it set now to run about
30 minutes
every hour and it gives enough time for
everything to charge up right now i
believe it's
set to to run at five we're going to
work on the scheduling to make sure that
we're working with optimal sun
and the best times to
aerate the pond with the fountain
ideally i would love to have the
fountain on
all the time however when it comes to
solar
we just can't do that with that setup
that i have i was actually looking at a
bubbler setup so
anyways if you like this video go ahead
and give it a thumbs up leave a comment
down below on maybe some suggestions on
how to make
the box better until next time guys
get outside stay safe and i will see you
then